make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay we are picking up with the
Marauders Marauders issue number two
here's the thing I love Marauders like I
love what's going on with the Marauders
it's awesome and it's an absolute blast
like I'm glad to see they're kind of
doing that right like I'm glad to see
that each individual title as part of
Dawn of X has its own kind of like tone
vent like its own feel it's one of the
things that's very easy to mess up and
it's one of the things is very easy to
loose right like where you launch a
title and they all feel the same well I
like that was a problem in Marlin in 90s
like everything in the 90s felt the same
I mean some of it was kind of cool ah
but everything kind of felt the same and
so the cool thing about this is that
each one of the stories kind of had
their own little tone here their own
kind of system going on that when it
comes to this particular story what we
picked up with in the last video is that
basically Kitty Pryde had formed her own
group right she was basically the
Marauders and just kind of going out and
the initial the initial plan they're
really seen for her to just kind of
figure out what the nature and function
of her team was not what this does it's
kind of give us an answer to that and
basically tell us what's going forward
from there but the idea is that this
initially picks up really with a
conversation between Emma Frost and and
what looks like this stuff or cuckoos
and initially he's just kind of like
okay like they basically decline her
offer
and she makes reference to something
called the Lord Imperial now the way
this works here is remember there's
always kind of a hierarchy when it comes
to these different positions within the
various organizations that exists out
there right the only exception to that
is the the quiet council right the quiet
councils kind of split up into different
different factions different groups but
each of them all kind of have an equal
power but they all sort of run their own
little area but there's no kind of like
oversee or formal I guess you could
argue this more McTaggart but she seems
really hands-off and we don't really
know exactly what all she's doing aside
from just simply seeming to kind of
guide people instead when it comes to
this and it's kind of a break away from
tradition the Hellfire Trading Company
basically has or at least what they're
looking for is a Lord Imperial which
oversees the entire Hellfire trading
company and that's a break away from
tradition because remember the Hellfire
Club has historically been this
organization that for the most part the
inner circle wasn't really known by a
lot of people most people didn't know
the inner circle existed at all and and
for the most part the inner circle use
this kind of anonymity combined with his
vast wealth to basically influence
global policy in its favor itís not
necessarily dominate the world but
they're basically a mass lot of money
and power and influence and so having it
like an individual who will reside over
all of them it's kind of intriguing here
is
it's pretty interesting to see what
direction that's gonna take but you know
with with the stepper kakou seemingly
turning down this offer presumably for
for the Lord Imperial if not for the
position of the red king or red queen
then what it does is it basically jumps
over to Sebastian Shaw now remember the
idea behind this is that the pal fire
training company operates in two fronts
the first is the front facing aspect of
it and the second is the black market
and the reason why is because in order
for core color to generate income it
basically has to provide a good or a
service that people want to buy and
that's why the idea of Kurkova kind of
manufacturing these these drugs are
these substances that can like add years
onto your life or can cure any kind of
mental disease or anything like that are
being offered right because it's
basically kind of like a pharmaceutical
industry this being offered by mutants
that just crushes anything that's being
offered by you know any existing major
market that's out there right now right
like no pharmaceutical company out there
can compete with what it is a grower has
and it's why they're dominating the
market but what you have out there are
count for countries that by virtue of
their population will basically say yes
we support Cocola and we do want to take
part in the various drugs and things
they have that can improve the lives of
our citizens then you have those
countries who choose not to support them
now some countries choose not to support
kokoa because of the fact that like if
the leader of the country chose to that
people would revolt and they would
basically kill the leader and all the
people in power and put somebody in
there who doesn't support curcumin or
because the leader doesn't want to feel
like a dictator that rules the country
with an iron fist and they don't care
what the people want and so the idea
here is that for those countries that
basically support kokoa that's where
Emma Frost comes in why she [ __ ] this
is okay we're gonna lead all these
different these different things to this
country we're gonna give them you know
the various medicines and supplies of
cacoa which of course they're gonna pay
for it for the black market aspect
basically those countries that for
whatever reason cannot publicly support
Cocola but still want access to all
their medicines they can buy them
through the black market and Sebastian
Shaw is the one who's supposed to be
providing this what Sebastian Shaw has
been doing is actually deviating out of
his line he's been going to like
countries out there that basically
support her color and then providing
them with medical supplies or providing
them with the kind of things that Cocola
can offer kind of deviating out of his
Lane and so as a result of that Kitty
Pryde really at the moment seems to
serve as a kind of checks and balance
right and this instance it was basically
like okay things have kind of gone awry
Kitty Pryde team was sent in and they're
basically gonna seize the ship of
Sebastian Shaw on the orders of Emma
Frost
and as one of these things were kind of
like stay in your lane do what you're
supposed to do otherwise this is gonna
happen time and time again and you need
that like like you need that kind of
system in place if there if it was just
kind of like okay so we're like the
Hellfire training company just go ahead
and do whatever you want to
there'd be no order in no structure and
everything that exists in krakoa in
terms of the role the mutants play the
kind of things they provide and how they
more or less manipulate the world
markets is really done by maintaining
order and structure it has to function
that way otherwise everything they've
built on a financial aspect comes
crashing down
and so what is ins up doing is actually
ends up picking up with the buddha
sebastian shaw which is actually being
led by Batroc the leaper
now backtrack the Libra he was a cool
guy well he was an old-school Captain
America villain he did um what was he I
think was uh he was a French kickboxer
he was awesome like it was fun to watch
him his stories where he would like
fight Captain America it was fun to read
those comics him back in the day didn't
really view those too much anymore but
that's the cool thing about this is a
kitty pryde is kind of release her
Marauders are kind of a Swiss Army knife
so to speak for the mutant nation of
krikawa insofar as what they're doing
here is it basically kind of maintained
the the order of things insofar as
Sebastian Shaw or ensure Sebastian
Shaw's vessels only go to black markets
but then there were also liberating
mutants from countries that won't let me
sleeve in order to go to core color
right so they're kind of covering a
bunch of different things but what is it
happening here is that once Kitty Pryde
and all then finally get onto the vessel
itself they essentially sink it where
does kind of a funny thing and Batroc in
them can't really do a whole lot to stop
her I mean that's one of the things that
was established in the previous issue of
the Marauders its Kitty Pryde like
running in and like literally a lone
gunman right her ability to phase
through all kinds of things basically
makes her seemingly unstoppable
one intern like once the ship is sunk
they basically say hey look here's our
new vessel it's a great big huge yacht
this is like equipped with weapons and
all kinds of crazy stuff but but
basically what you're getting here is
kind of this pirate life now force Emma
Frost basically turns into Sebastian
Shawn says hey look so like we basically
suck your ship so stay in your lane and
and don't deviate again otherwise you're
gonna get more of the same and that's
kinda the funny thing is Sebastian Shaw
can't really stop it right I mean
there's really nothing he can do here
because he's the one that errors say he
says like I want to call together a
meeting of the quiet consul and
basically they say okay what's your case
of bash and it's like well I've been
deviating away from my task instead of
providing you know the the things that
we have the the goods and services that
we have to the black market I've been
going to like the public markets which
is what
Ross is supposed to do but I've been
doing it instead and so basically we're
doubling up and we're not really
slurring the black markets I'm not doing
my job and like she sucked my [ __ ]
because of it she punished me for it and
that's a problem I mean how do you
justify that right like how do you make
that case like I wasn't doing my job and
I was penalized for it it's like the
most entitled attitude ever maybe was
get somebody to replace you like
somebody who can do your job like it's
it's it's a funny little thing here but
like that's Luther the spot that he's in
and this is the important thing to
understand about Emma Frost right the
way this she depicts us in this
conversation with with sebastian shaw
the way that she depicts us is this is
the way the game is gonna be played this
is how it's going to function you can
play just like we tell you you could do
what we tell you to or we can replace
you with somebody who will Emma Frost
does not care and that's the coolest
thing about her characters I'm afraid I
always kind of had this confidence it's
kind of haughty hubris attitude of like
I can do what I want to and nobody can
get in my way right like there are there
are two kinds of people in this world
the ones that I can work with and the
ones who get in my way and if you get in
my way then I'll just have you spend the
rest of your life you're believing
you're a dog and just barking and
carrying on now following this Kitty
Pryde and her group basically travel to
Taipei here's a cool thing about this is
well I love this so much they're
literally pirates right like they do
have higher it's thing I feel like okay
she's like we're gonna travel to Taipei
and we're gonna meet with the person the
contact we're supposed to meet here and
then like once they end up realizing
it's Bishop bishops like your your job
is to stay here until you're told who it
is that you want to meet with and they
basically go into like a local tattoo
parlor and get tattoos and they go drink
it looks like the most fun ever if you
do this is gonna be awesome it's like a
party on the high seas but here's the
other thing to point usually other thing
to bear in mind to you is this is Kitty
Pryde probably at her best if I'm being
honest as a person when reading as long
as I have hiking this is Kitty Pryde
probably some of the best riding for her
character that I've seen in a long time
even like after all-new all-different
marvel where she was a leader of the
x-men the prom is that during that time
the x-men story sucked right because
Marvel was trying to take the x-men in
order boost the Inhumans and nobody
wanted that everybody wanted the x-men
and so kind of like giving us that
version of Kitty Pryde in that
leadership role combined with like
amazing storytelling is awesome right
like she's got like this broken nose
with this bandage on her nose she's got
like this kind of flannel thing around
her neck chins up stealing like this
cloak you know and and it's amazing
because she basically has like these
tattoos on her fingers it's a holdfast
she
looks like a pirate but ultimately they
end up finding out the person they're
supposed to meet is a guy named gateway
now gateway is an old-school carriage
right gateways been around whoo God
since like uncanny x-men 229 and the
idea behind this was that gateway was
originally used by a group called the
Reavers now the Reavers are something
you guys have probably heard of before
and they were basically kind of like
this cyborg faction that basically like
used gateway who could who could
teleport people as it means to like loot
and plunder he's just like from
Australia I think he's an Aborigine I'm
not gonna sweat it out though and like
nothing's known about this guy's past we
even know what his real name this right
like all you know is that he's referred
to as gateway because that's the name
the Reavers gave him ultimately over the
years he ended up siding against the
Reavers joined the x-men and became a
huge part of the team for a long long
time but he's there to teleport them to
where it is that they're supposed to go
and then the the place where teleporting
to is actually one to this great big
huge yacht this like outfitted with like
cannons and stuff like that like it's
literally this multimillion-dollar
luxury yacht this been outfitted like
retrofitted with like all these weapons
and different things but the other part
of it is that Emma Frost has basically
removed Sebastian Shaun's ability to
determine who the who's gonna be the Red
King of the Red Queen as part of the
Trinity more or less of the Hellfire
Trading Company now of course this
pisses Sebastian Shaw off to no end but
at the end of the day like he overplayed
his hand he thought he could basically
kind of get out there and do his own
thing sort of step outside the bounds
that have been created for him and
ultimately he's paying the price right
that's that's the price that gets paid
for the role that for the role that he's
played here and so as a result of that
what is up going on here is is basically
like Emma Frost like Waller our new red
queen is here and that's what I end up
finding out that is Kitty Pryde and can
we all just admit that Kitty Pryde dress
as a pirate looks amazing she looks
amazing as a pirate dude it's one of the
coolest out of isn't the coolest
versions of Kitty Pryde did I've ever
seen it looks straight out of Pirates of
the Caribbean right like x-men of the
Caribbean it looks awesome
Jerry Duggan's still got it man like you
go and you read stories like infinity
Wars and it's like okay man what was
even going on and even like with his
guardians of the galaxy run to a degree
it's like
I'm not really but like looking at his
handling of marauders dude cheery
Duggan's still got it man like it's is
awesome it's if you're not reading it
you're sorely missing out it's not even
about like crazy plot threads or
anything like that it's just good
old-fashioned fun and like you need a
comic like that it's part of Dawn of X
just a good old-fashioned fun comic book
to read now I'm sure the plots will get
more complicated as time goes on and the
thoughts would become more significant
but like if they're gonna be invading
like showing up on the doorstep of
countries so to speak and visually
saying like we're gonna free mutants or
they're gonna be fighting off areas
forces the high seas they're gonna need
a vessel to do it and having a
multi-million dollar yacht outfitted
with cannons it's basically like a
luxury battleship is awesome well that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comment explain it make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
you